[Music]
so welcome everyone at first I'd like to
thank the organizers Sujata and the
others who made it possible for us all
to be here today so the topic of how to
visualize neural network parameters and
activities it's relevant for many of us
who are developing models in deep
learning or if you're going in the more
research direction and you want to be
able to come up with something new find
something that will enable other
investigators or end-users to benefit
from getting intuition to the into the
process first off can everyone hear me
clearly in the back ok great that's so
so let's so about me so I originally was
working in neuroscience research and
University of Texas at San Antonio
and I was interested in the brain and
the activity of the brain looking at
brain activations and currently I'm a
master's student in cognitive science at
the University of Austin Brook in
Germany where I'm working a bit in the
math department making some
visualizations with d3.js and writing my
thesis with a company called Pelt Ariane
and Stockholm say I software company so
so and another thing I'm working with
Intel is AI software innovator and I can
tell you more about that later if you're
interested they basically support early
prototyping and using their software and
hardware and at the end I'll have some
gifts for you courtesy of Intel and I
was able to bring some things for for
you guys to to have I'll tell you at the
end so so the first question might be
why is this relevant to us to understand
to get the intuition about TIG neural
networks if the predictions are useful
that that might be enough for for our
boss and my boss might be happy with
that on the other hand there's other
people who are very interested in
understanding
why so the second keynote topic was was
very relevant the interpretations or
credibility of networks and models is
essential for many people in society so
specifically all introduced to projects
that are very relevant Jason you since
keys deep visualization tool box which
is useful for visualizing neural network
activation for convolutional neural
networks as well as Carpathia's text
base visualizations for recurrent neural
networks and sensor flows tensor board
which many of us who use tensor flow
have found useful and other notable
projects and a summary so why is it
relevant to understand and get intuition
about the activity of these neural
networks one part I happen to be biased
about it's the desire to really
understand what's happening so
especially if you're working with
natural models and you're trying to make
a prediction about why is this part of
the brain being active rather than
another and a certain task you you want
to be able to not only make a prediction
but also to explain and understand
what's happening so there's an example
given by Noam Chomsky it's a camera
pointed out of window can make can make
better predictions than any physicist
could about what's going to happen next
but it doesn't give insight into the
underlying principles so those are the
principles that were after if we're
interested in science deep learning so
for end-users it's also relevant to be
able to explain and interpret so whether
it's a self-driving car that's having
that has to make a decision in one case
or if it's a a financial model that
you're trying to analyze it's going to
be useful for end-users to be able to
understand why certain predictions were
made also for model developers who who
go down the path of having to build
models they'll benefit from every
intuition that they can get and also
increasing performance overall depends
on having an understanding about the
mechanisms in neural network
itself there's a quote from fireman
which I happen to find inspiring says
what I cannot create I do not understand
and I think now because we have so much
power to create with these tools it
brings us to the question of saying well
if we can't explain it we probably also
don't understand it as well so
introducing convolutional neural
networks so convolutional neural
networks are commonly associated with
that image detection and it works
basically by taking an input image and
convolve a filter a filter kernel across
the image and create a feature map so
like this in it in this case we can see
a convolutional filter with involved
over the input image to create emboss
feature map so basically at low levels
it works like an edge detector sorry
it's detector wood and deep the deep
convolutional visualization tool box is
really useful because it lets you
visualize several different types of
features put the low levels and high
levels you can download it and play with
it in Python it new sense Keys
repository and github and he's running
Alex net and cafe and I'm gonna yeah
break the rule about no live demos give
you a quick lap demo because it's
beautiful and gives you a lot of
intuition really quick
so so here we we see the deep
visualization tool box and this is the
Alex net running in cafe and these are
the various from left to right the
various layers of the network so a first
convolutional layer bullying layer
normalization layer then onward until
the end of it to the fully connected
layers and it tells us on the left so
this is a input image and it tells us
the classification so this is using
image net belief yes and we can see for
various images with the classification
is so it at the first layers our filters
are pretty basic on the right we see in
these the nine squares here these are
images from the training data that are
producing the most activation for each
of these given units so each of these
squares is a unit within the layer and
the top and bottom are our images
generated to produce the most activation
also let me show you so let's go back to
the so here's a visualization of images
that were generated to produce the most
activation in the layer okay so we can
turn on the camera the webcam and we can
get a live preview of how that works
there's a fairly pale white guy in front
of you let me show you
so given this convolutional filter we
can see that the is the activation will
be corresponding to edges on the left
side
so this will show how this unit course
is activated based on that filter and
then on the the units of the ride shows
the activation of edges on the other
side so at low level you get low level
features such as edges colors and the
convolutional network uses these and
builds on them to produce a final
classification it's quite interesting at
higher levels at the higher layers you
get to the fifth the convolutional layer
you can see there's one neuron that
lights up in the detection it detects
faces so there's a even though this
neural network was designed to Train to
the model was designed to classify
images so people versus animals versus
school buses it there's a face detector
embedded within it so what's interesting
about that is there could be a lot of
other features that could be extracted
from from image Anette for example from
four models that are trained for
higher-level
purposes lower level features could be
found that are embedded within so and
here are the images that that that this
neuron most was most important for
producing the final classification for
and here are the parts of the images the
parts of these images which were most
relevant to the classification so if if
you either obscure these parts of the
image it would either classify
differently or if you perturb it and
it's also possible to see with this tool
relationships between layers so how do
lower levels lower layers relate to high
level high layer activations so that's
really neat if you want to see your face
light up on a neural network come by
afterwards we can check out and another
important neural network a useful for
visualizing is recurrent neural networks
so what the recurrent neural network one
can see the relationship between
sequences that are a models trained on
sequences and to see visually how
relevant certain parts of that the data
corresponds to to the output so in this
and a recurrent neural network you have
input fed into a hidden layer a hidden
layer which depends both on the current
state and also in the previous state of
the network and that then produces a
output so now put classification
prediction generating text so forth
and so an example of how that works so
if your sequences hello word hello
there's a four unique characters in
hello so you would need a one hunt
encoding for four entries and each
letter would correspond with the the
corresponding element so H would be the
first second he would be a second L
would be the third and if you were
trying to predict the fifth letter in
this sequence you would wanted to
predict o as the fifth letter and the
way that roughly works is you have an
input layer and matrix multiplication to
to give you the hidden layer which then
also is an activation function is
applied and produces an output layer
then in further time steps
you have the hidden layer being affected
by both the new input that's coming in
and also by the previous hidden layer so
the hidden layer represents the kind of
embedding of like a it's like a hidden
it's a hidden layer
it's an embedding that's useful for
storing memory from previous learnings
and so carrying the memory forward and
in terms of an activation function
applied to the way matrix times the
input plus a transition matrix times the
previous time state hidden there so
visualizing that I was pretty clever
from carbody - he looked into the cell
the cells of the lsdm and kind of like
if you were looking into a brain and if
you were to find there's certain part of
the brain was active whenever you were
talking with your friend versus when
you're talking another part active when
you talk with your your coworkers so we
found that the there are certain cells
that activate for example when you're
approaching the end of a line so there's
a part of the ilist Ian even though it
wasn't trained specifically for that it
learns this along the way also you can
visualize with text there cells that
turn on only within inside quotes so
it's clear here that there's some
context that's being learned and even
though it's understood if you're
generating text with the with an RNN
that there's also features that are
going to be learned and incorporated
into the into producing accurate text
cathay also trained on cells that that
activate only within if statements so
with so it's pretty useful to think
about that or maybe interesting to
consider that syntax and semantics
context or things that we've defined
heuristic li there might be further
analytical explanations that we don't
that we're not aware of we could
discover through these kinds of methods
tensorflow also has another feature
called tensor board
that's useful for visualizing weight
histograms for example also doing
embedding visualizations so if you have
worked avec embeddings you can see them
and 2d or 3d I just have to attach to
the summaries to make sure that it saves
whatever it's saves those weights and
also the graph visualization which is
useful when you're when you're designing
your model or if you're finding that
you're not your models not learning or
there's a bug it's quite useful because
for example you can see that the color
encoding for layers will be the same if
the the hyper parameters are the same so
if you find that there's a bug
something's not working you can check
this and make sure that there isn't for
example two convolutional layers that
one has a slightly different setting if
so they would have different colors
useful for debugging also embedding
visualizations with PCA and t-sne we can
take a look at that later if you like
and the playground so this is more for
getting general intuition about how
neural networks work so if you want to
see how this for example the information
move from from one layer of the network
to another how does the the model depth
affect the performance this is really
useful for explaining that and the past
year tensor board added some new ability
to add extensions so recently we saw an
handwriting recognition plugin that can
do live handwriting prediction and it
will basically learn the style of a
person's handwriting so the ability to
customize visualizations for specific
projects provides a lot of opportunities
so if you're working on a project for a
long time and you want to develop a
consistent visualization you can share
that with the open source community
through tensorflow and heat mapping org
has some and some other very nice
visualizations
like to open up and [ __ ] with you as
well so here we we can see the EM nest
predictions and it'll it will predict
your from the input it'll show which
parts of the which parts of the input
are most relevant to the classification
using they call layer wise relevance
propagation and LRP and there's a
toolbox with available and get out so
make a nice pretty one more or less and
it predicts it correctly and it shows
you that which parts of the input we're
most relevant so it's useful to play
with to get an intuition also a cafe
model shows you which parts of the image
input are important for the
classification and they predict a peak
at and the text one as well
so given input text lets you classify
explain it so if if we went to this to
the second keynote we heard about other
projects like lime and li5 which do
roughly the same thing okay so other
notable projects include the University
of Austin Brooke colleague of mine here
is helping to develop a platform it's a
pie cutie visualization that'll take any
neural network model whether it's in
cafe torch tensorflow so forth and to be
able to visualize live the unit
activations it's very early development
stage so we started about a month ago
but you can check out the github make a
pull request and also some other useful
as useful article on how to use TSN
effectively so t-sne is so useful for
visualizing the embeddings or to
visualize the data distribution high
dimensional data so an example here I
created a genre music melody generator
using magenta and I wanted to see how
just how what the distance was between
different music genres so if a music was
encoded with both classical and metal
but but compare that to musics that were
included with both classical and rap for
example and through that you can find
what is the distance between genres and
so here it was possible to see for
example that classical over here is
quite separate from say a country over
here so t-sne picked up on that pretty
well
whereas pca probably would take some
more finessing to get to get it useful
li5 in line were explained earlier and
so summarize you can explore neural
network features much more easily if
they're visualizable or if if you can
kind of take them out of their context
and put them into a tool that gives
people inside and there's also a
possibility of discovering these latent
coatings latent features that were not
otherwise intuitive or visible and so
deep learning has a lot of promise for
that creating tools to help guide
scientists find the right model because
it's not obvious and which which models
to pick until someone has already tested
it and compared it to other models so
it's it's one of our hopes that we'll be
able to create a higher level API for
that and also this scientific research
has high social impact as Christine
mentioned and the the keynote that not
only it's the lost art requiring certain
interpretability factors to be present
but it also is useful for for the end
user to to know what's guiding them so
we have some image sources and yeah
couple couple of screens were taken from
some useful tensorflow
YouTube video and also since Keith's
YouTube video which was helpful and a
little plug if you're interested in
Intel's machine learning and deep
learning webinars they have a link you
can check that out here and so we were
able to get some free Amazon vouchers
for you if you create a project through
the the Europe's Deb mesh for Intel so
the place for sharing projects and
collaborating so they said about 50
euros that's your so I've been
recommending out alright thanks a lot
for your time
any questions any questions
yes CNN visualization with the
misclassified example so in the deep
visualization toolbox for example or
generally yeah sure it's actually the
most the most common this classification
that I've seen is where you try to have
a class if I use a person and it ended
almost always fails
so it's detected me as everything from
like a teapot to a bowtie so I think
it's not like robust against that kind
of thing I'll be happy to show you
afterwards if you want one more hands-on
demo wants to see their face light up on
our network you got to do it yourself to
really get the experience okay thank you
very much
[Applause]
you